hey guys i'm ryan right I believe
BuzzFeed has released a new video called
people try the Charlie Charlie challenge
prank video yeah I don't know what the
challenge is the Charlie Charlie
challenge
I want to watch the video and be
surprised this is a reaction channel we
don't know that hold on Charlie Charlie
are we safe yeah so after a brief
investigation we've decided that this
Charlie Charlie thing is kind of just an
Internet hoax Charlie Charlie are you
there Charlie Charlie are you there
Charlie Charlie are you here Charlie
Charlie are you in a chocolate factory
so for the duration of this video I'm
just gonna mess with people I am so
superstitious I don't know why I'm doing
this don't know if I can set this I'm
like my nerves are a little I'm a little
shaky
you're shaking I know it's terrifying
Charlie Charlie can we play Charlie's
here Charlie is in the building
it ain't Charlie it's somebody else
grandma sorry try do you wanna hurt us
funny accurate oh my god
I think I'm done Charlie Charlie can we
play no no no no no no no no no no no
really
no stop if this is the thing you need to
stop it what what are you doing oh yeah
Charlie Charlie will you appear does he
blow on it I don't know I'm not seeing
what I'm Charlie hi right all connecting
over in Mexican demon so thank you
Charlie oh and just for safety sake
goodbye Charlie Charlie Charlie will
mean my BAE work out alright so I get
what the challenge is but can you please
just explain it so I make sure I get
what the challenge is so basically it
comes like this Mexican demon named
Charlie and yours that's how you summon
it but he's like it's kind of like a get
a Ouija board just like your only
Charlie are you here and it's supposed
to move and like it got popular because
people were posting vines about moving -
yes and like freaking out and then you
have to say goodbye Charlie in order for
the demon to go back or something so
you're like okay so it is what I thought
except for the goodbye Charlie apart but
everything else like okay good prank I
don't get how he was blowing on it that
I don't either cuz he wasn't doing it in
a very obvious way I thought he was
gonna do magnets or something yeah but
no I think he was just being like
Charlie Charlie in it like moves I don't
know okay so that's what we're gonna do
are you here we're gonna yeah but we're
not gonna like thank you yeah we're
gonna see if it actually works
my favorite Martin is like they were
trying to do it
and he got really mad he's like man just
this [ __ ] better do it like he started
yelling at it and it moved in me like
sure I should sector actually see Brian
yeah thanks for ruining the whole video
that could have been funny I could have
been haha about it for now I'm not now
I'm sad about it cuz you didn't let me
watch it and said yeah that's a real
hero what are you what are you like a 40
year old I can argue like a four year
old don't be a [ __ ] well there's got to
be a way we can fake this now I like
that it's like get a Ouija board
yes and Mexican demons I know what
that's like I'm dating a Mexican demon
right now whenever she's mad she becomes
a Mexican demon that is so mean well
it's true that is so mean no it's
[ __ ] like don't call your girlfriend
demon no when she gets mad okay do you
remember um the First Lord of the Rings
when Bilbo is like telling Gandalf
you're trying to take the ring for
yourself and then Gandalf is like boom
boom dragon you like Rises that's what
it's like liver Annika and I in our
relationship when she gets mad I'm
always like you took one of my french
fries and that she's like Ryan right I
did not take your fries I'm trying to
help you yeah I know
oh yeah every girl when they're mad
becomes a Mexican demon or whatever type
of race they are mm-hmm
facts anyway guys thanks for tuning in
if you're new to the channel subscribe
to the real rejects porfavor and you can
check out sentiment of Sally's channel
it's a very good channel I know that was
supposed to be my Spanier but then I
crossed it with my ghetto Mexican
character so it just came across like a
pervert you falls off a smug Instagram
atwitter where if we get enough
followers product placement for things
such as turkey sandwiches
part of it turkey sandwiches are great
they actually help you sleep and because
turkey produces a certain type of
hormone that helps you sleep high in
protein
but the benefit of it is that the high
in protein and then you sleep helps you
produce more sperm cells so when you in
Jack you laid on a girl's face it will
produce even twice as much sperm because
you had turkey and it tastes good
because it's high in protein so she can
bulk up a little bit
turkey sandwiches people